قانونيا بالعكس الست ليها حقها ولها حاجات
كتيره جدا بس احنا بنتكلم على
التقاليد اكتر بصي انا في الاول ببص على
القصه القصه بتحكي عن ايه
وبعد كده من خلال القصه انت بتلاقي ان
القصه تهم في اشياء كثيره قوي قوي قوي
وفيها عمق لحاجات كتير ومشاكل كثير
بالمناسبه قضيه الميراث
بالبيئات الفلاحيه بيئات المزارعين الناس
بالنسبه لهم الارض اكثر من قيمه ماديه
الارض لا تقدر بالنسبه لهم بالمال الارض
عزوه والارض جاه والارض مكانه فعمليا اذا
كانوا حيورثوا البنات
ودول ناس يعني بينجبوا كتير لو عنده مس
بنات فالخمس بنات حيورثوا
ملكيه بتاعته حتتجزا هتتفتت وتروح لناس
تانيين اللي هم ازواج البنات
الحقيقه في بعض الاحيان قد تفوق الدراما
في قسوتها فقد اشارت دراسه اجريت في
محافظتين بالصعيد في قنا وسوهاج الى ان
حوالي
95% من نساء المحافظتين يحرمن من ميراثهن
في الارض بسبب التقاليد وتنظر المحاكم
144 الف قضيه نزاع على الميراث سنويا فضلا
عن جرائم تصل الى القتل بسبب النزاع حول
الميراث احنا بنتكلم اكتر حاجه عن فكره
الست تاخد فلوس ما تاخدش ارض من حقها لو
حقها يعني الدراما التي ساهمت من قبل في
تغيير قوانين متعلقه بالاحوال الشخصيه
وحصول المراه على حقوقها قد تجد صعوبه في
تغيير عادات ترى السخت منذ مئات السنين
اهم قضيه بتصرخ لها العمل هي قضيه المراه
لان الست يبقى الهازمه ماليه مستقله يبقى
من حقها يبقى لها حساب في بنكي يبقى من
حقها ترس زي ما الشرع قال وتبقى دراما احد
اهم ادوات التغيير في المجتمع وخاصه عندما
يتميز العمل الفني بكافه عناصره رند ابو
العزم لمساء العربيه القاهره لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات